[Music]
these lifelike dinosaur puppets will
star in the new Jurassic world live tour
which debuts in arenas around the US
this fall the show is produced by Feld
Entertainment the same company behind
Disney on Ice and Marvel Universe live
[Music]
you're gonna be face to face with actual
dinosaurs we've done a lot of
development a lot of research to make in
these dinosaurs really lifelike the
texture of their skin their eyes the way
they move the speed at which they move
everything is like super realistic the
show's scenic team designed the dinosaur
puppets using the CGI models of the
creatures seen in the Jurassic film
franchise there's a foam under layer
that houses all the electronics and
gives it the shape that's needed and
then we cover the entirety of it in its
scaling pattern its skin it's really
impressive to see even the little
nuances the eye blinks the little [ __ ]
to the head to the side the idea is that
you can see what the dinosaur is feeling
by what that Dino tear is doing
internally the puppets are controlled by
Dino tears who not only have to act like
dinosaurs they also have to be in
incredible physical condition because
the costumes weigh over 100 pounds make
no mistake these are absolutely athletes
and they are elite athletes at that they
have diverse backgrounds whether that be
from the exceptional training in martial
arts dance gymnastics they need to be
super fit to wear that weight and to
really move and feel it very light on
their feet even though they have a
hundred and twenty additional pounds on
their body the team gave our producer a
60 pound weight vest to get a sense of
what the costume feels like for the
diner peers we're and ask you to be in a
very unnatural position this is not a
normal position for a human being to be
in if they're manipulating and being a
Dino tear
so now you're gonna step forward and a
lot of its in sort of a semi squat
position and their gait is much larger
much wider so these are the cause
excessive stress on joints and backs and
things of that nature as well done some
lunges along with familiar faces
light-blue the Velociraptor the show
will introduce a new character to the
jurassic universe a Troodon named gene
so we've got a Troodon Troodon -
believed to be the most intelligent
dinosaur that lived so our lead
character is a dinosaur called Jeanne
short for genius and she really forms
the backbone of our story and it's her
intelligence which really inspired us
and in what to explore with our new
story
this is truly a marriage of the
fundamentals of hand puppetry with the
fundamentals of full-body character
works so these bike breaks here are
responsible for the head looking side to
side it is a multi-step process to train
a human to walk like a dinosaur that is
for sure a lot of it starts with out of
costume work first before the Dino tears
suit up they practice fundamental
movements with hand puppets there you go
we're looking for people not only with
those strengths and stamina but also
people who can really manage sensory
overload working inside confined
costumes in the dark with limited
hearing limited vision while being taxed
physically so these dinosaurs look
amazing close-up but how will they look
for people sitting in the cheap seats
[Music]
it's so important that everyone who
comes to the Jurassic world live tour no
matter where they're sitting that they
have a great experience we make sure
that all the dinosaurs all the show
elements have a really high level of
detail that actually makes it read from
far away no matter where they are
positioned in the arena the show
promises one element that people
watching from the rafters will
definitely be able to see a full-sized
animatronic t-rex which at the time of
this report was still being built and
tested
it cost to create a lifelike animatronic
for horserace no yes million not gonna
answer anymore the producer wouldn't
give specifics about the budget but she
did say it's one of the most expensive
shows the company has ever produced and
even referenced a famous quote from
Jurassic Park
we've spared no expense on this
production spent no expense spared no
expense spared no expense dinosaurs are
pretty expensive
[Music]